hold on right there Oh who the hell are
you hello I'm Linda Stasi I remember I
see you don't have to I mean it's
somebody who reviewed this stinker of a
movie I know there's only one proper way
to do it yeah what's a in rhyme that
actually sounds impossible actually it's
remarkably simple I'm surprised more
people don't do it sounds like a awful
lot of work you ever tried it no give it
a shot you pick it up in like two
seconds all right let's try it
[Music]
studio logos those shiny they beckoned
blowed out the runtime by 42 seconds
inside his snowflake Hopkins is in this
that wasn't too bright his roles as
phoned-in as the one in the right also
is this such a holiday Spectre your kids
being soothed by Hannibal Lecter you
must see to believe
stretch out a short full of imagination
at two hours how do you still need
narration Ron Howard directed I'm having
my doubts this looks like some farts not
Tim Burton's sneezed out this looks less
like the cartoon that you know and more
like an ad for Universal Studios there's
little variety of humor oh shoot this
film save you 2% sight-gags ain't it
also if there isn't a plot to fill out a
movie distract them with phlegm ease and
flimsy Xand floozies Russian nesting
doll horn players really Oompa Loompa
rap has more plausibility it's painfully
obvious this outsides inside you can
almost see where the air conditioner
hides money in two different slots is a
site that will leave the drawers short
at the end of the night
really the kid lost to the store cliche
perhaps Taylor Momsen can steer her the
right way not to be grungy and scroogie
and such but this Christmas obsession is
too much that's bad business practice
it'll take its toll not that it matters
for Black Friday assholes there's no
safe device to help ornaments fit off
knee or cat all or some dr. Seuss if
your decorations obscure all the tree it
means you're American go productivity
that's racist and why the hell are we
following these to save lives up here in
a big cave oh to bring up a legend we
already know is true it's courting who
girls in search for who centered
around finding weird doors they can
knock
that managed to scare him huh hard to
believe I got worst nightmares working
at Chucky Cheese really bailed rewrite
them suppose a bad guy hates that easily
hate it you'll feel this more often than
anticipated
when apples are scarce and onion will
pass to help make you look that much
more like an ass the Grinch hated
Christmas the whole Christmas season now
please don't ask why because you know
the damn reason those two look strange
there's no denying this but a paper
faced Jedi sneaks into the mix fart
jokes and burp jokes are already tough
made even lamer with a visible puff
everyone Krabappel doesn't seem
superfluous this child's book it seems
perfectly on hobbled so why all the
silly fake words like Kerr bobbled their
treatment of mail leaps packages wrecked
but they're still somehow better than
Federal Express
I don't finish you explosion of hair
that do could rifle Queen Amidala flare
what's worse ignoring this lineup of
jerks or that no one knows how this blip
in line works actually no it should just
take a day for the old habit trusses
males funny that way also why is mail
fraud the plan you prepared is it just
because I main characters there
yes jury Duty's a reason to shout but in
this weird-ass who-ville I check that
out post office rooms unattended
forever giving Grinch time for his evil
endeavors this machine doesn't seem very
good at its job isn't smashing these
packages kind of a prop The Grinch now
possesses Spiderman powers or does he
stick simply because he never showers a
dog sneeze gives away his dark hiding
spot so why did he bring him doesn't
help out a lot uh huh the fragile
stamper is deadly how could a Christmas
here be one of great joy with a post
office smashing presents and toys so the
dog is really the hero you see make up
your own lassie joke we're too lazy the
printer saves the girl redemptions
fulfilled so why is there an hour and a
half left to kill his ninja Packaging is
way too together you've been practicing
your Christmas wrapping whatever I'm
gonna stretch time and leave out what
was charming use filler lines like just
insert the last line we used on this one
Mario tubes give the finger to physics
and gravity momentum know where to stick
it the door drops the bag and then the
next shot gets through you should see
what he did and the takes that weren't
used wait was this written before the
script was it says something different
than the movie does if anything her
worlds perpetually not changing was that
not the point of her cooking complaining
Christmas cannot answer you it's a
season giving the song sequence even
less reason nope the dog drop that bag
did you forget put an arrow on there not
forgotten quite yet but we did our worst
you scared a little girl and messed up
the mail I think your worst is a bit of
a fail Grinch changes clothes while his
dog sees him shaken is it changing
screen needed
he's usually naked a whole 60 seconds -
Grinch echo talking as if the film's
running time didn't leave us sulking Oh
feelings Oh
so dad's penis goes in mom's vagina I
get it now
and so will the other kids kind of looks
just like your boss so pom Priscilla
babies delivered - folks can still bring
awesome infidelity jokes so that's how
it worked
did they say how that one kid look like
our boss who cares - most kids that joke
will be lost
it's the year 2000 so smashmouth of
course nothing more timeless than that
music source party is this they're all
dress like hoes a lot of bum persons are
setting to go a lesbian couple okay I'm
down for that
but why aren't they given the green
hairy brat perhaps he do better if you
don't name him Grinch did you think with
that name he'd fit in in a century also
green Chi babies they make nightmares
come true
this bastard sadistic Santa's fiery
debris all while the deer have
pre-existing injuries you like Martha
did you really need a reason to find
Christmas so rough isn't the town
strange holiday fetish enough it's just
the girl from the song my two front
teeth I hope the tooth fairies pay
double this week I don't like discussing
this Grinch you shut down Whoville when
you last heard his name openly discuss
now why don't you feel the same these
shots are so smokey is the town on fire
is Whoville just built on some old
burning tires
first off facial hair always gets the
chicks second what beard is this some
mental trick is this now a story of
interracial love let's maybe inspired
some furry chef for some reason he came
home that day so is Cindy just walking
between neighbor borders to get her
story in chronological order the teacher
is laughing who hired this witch any
school board would fire that bitch
before he reached school those cuts
would have healed plus hair too even
grown those spots they revealed so his
Christmas hatreds trace back to a girl I
guess then who boners mean all of the
world the fury for a world where sex
doesn't seem to exist there sure a ton
of cheap jokes not to miss bridges
backstory is better left dead he's a
butt ugly green hairy monster enough
said how can you tell the celebrations
apart you've had them for every damn day
so far Oh take care of those pesky
robberies self-injury incentives settle
his woes what kid-friendly vices this
movie's exposed Punchbowl attire seems
totally fine this party's where Mardi
Gras would draw the damn line
the qualities of a looter and who during
the who's talk like Smurfs with each
single breath but I don't spend a half
hour plotting the Smurfs death his book
of who just a discount Book of Mormon
except more believable and not quite as
dormant I believe that you will to
agreed six-year-old who we've only just
met we'll follow you though we don't
quite know you yet that's not how I hear
it from where I come from their
Christmas cheering is what I call
symptoms a tip or a slip you'll just
slide all the way down or bounce all the
way without dying on the ground
young Cindy just stumbled on some weird
sex act I know a few people who pay
money for that also no headphones around
here this late he could drown it out
with Johnny Depp sound effects tape she
would be scared if this weren't Jim
Carrey shtick we've seen this for years
we're kind of used to it
he mugs for a while it's really nothing
new all down for skipping this scene
thank you
no sign of the original storyline yet
and we're 40 minutes in did the script
just forget I'm not sure why falling to
her death makes her giggle yeah maybe
she's thinking dying tickles
convenient good timing never seems to
stand still just like for this you lure
the Grinch seems to kill did the cartoon
slow to a halt like this can we get to
the stole Christmas part as promised
yeah that's what her alone should be a
hate crime well I did include the scene
if you've got time how is it the Grinch
hasn't blown up this town ID who noop
this who Fez to the goddamn who grout do
you the Grinch wouldn't dance at this
ball he's a Grinch did you
read the book at all
though this is a song of which I'll
never tire it'll always be connected to
the awful chariots of fire the gift of a
Christmas shave ha ha a shaving joke
give that a 10 wait how exactly was that
funny to them please become mrs.
Augustus and I thought they were married
and now I'm told never I guess he waited
for the Grinch to score the meanest
marriage proposal ever wearing the nails
I see nothing but furry do my eyes
deceive me or are they just blurry to
this family film you and your kids flew
but Jim Carrey's in this so you knew it
go blue these folks have this coming
burn him down head to toe but we've seen
they have comps so why are they letting
this go I'll race joke really
we're going there folks actually good
that was a pretty funny joke but why
does this town need taxis anyway
who-ville's as large as a penguins
driveway there are tiny who's now I
think I missed that part
oh well let's see Grinch waste time in a
go-kart all right hey how about a nice
not a more useless line in this film
than that not shot there's a spare pre
decorated tree they should have used
that first instead of dangling
dangerously don't crash on James English
and run in front of the green screen
snorting uppers and downers stop dish Oh
so immediately one hour the plot now
unwinds go to watch the original twice
in that time tricky we know and you can
see why but at least we're attempting
you didn't even try that's animal
cruelty at least I think so
it shot so horrendously it's hard to
know who the hell singing please tell me
they bombed I've heard better versions
out of William Hong's mom
well thank you for waking all those
still asleep guess Johnny Kris kringles
not very discreet The Grinch apparently
is a big method actor there's no
motivation
he even directs the film better than the
director even with having located the
plot but film still enjoys wasting time
a whole lot I doubt he could start this
fan powered snow blower this thing
wouldn't power up Lee school lawnmower
if that would mean ending this movie
please try old the who's were all
dreaming sweet dreams without care did I
mention that Hannibal Lecter's still
scary because he is almost as much as
Jim Carrey adults who believe that Santa
is real screw it the film's almost over
I'll deal okay
moms in the winter or in I had to get
those if there's bugs in his teeth are
their moms and it snows come on kid you
can't recognize grinches voice he shows
you his face did you bring that damn
moist this gag is delightful and makes
everyone's day but dare I ask how these
goods get to its lay dr. Seuss people
get friendly to all next Grinch will act
next to transformer balls I guess
they're so used to when Santa visited
that no one wakes up when loud crimes
are committed
this dog pull sled looks kind of insane
it's putting Sarah McLachlan's pet ads
to shame you can't hurt Christmas mr.
mayor that's true but this movie comes
dangerously close to it - yeah
transformation so quick Whoville the
whole time was nothing but dicks
perhaps 1% would agree in the town the
rest would buy torches and burn his
house down Pretty Reckless Taylor Pretty
Reckless indeed that's not the joke you
want but the joke that you need every
who down in Whoville the tall and the
small except for the mayor right he's
still an asshole or was he part of the
one second change that evolved who
sizes that day me I'm still pissed
oh no what's he up to all down for
skipping this scene thank you
did she climb that that toy bag is huge
and why is she up there enjoying the
view
yeah I don't think so despite a big
heart that slave would demolish all his
Grinchy parts so people acknowledge
there's death in this flick hey the gap
Humber cellars I don't know this world
stick still not bored yet try some lame
ascii jokes they'll get a big laugh for
senile folks what's this guy doing is
that really your plan you can't save the
tree with your one dumbass hand hi I'm
stone Christmas plus arson car theft and
property damage but let's end this
cooker I'm sure we can manage no one can
tell that by simply a glance check the
damn bag don't leave it to chance
also they held up quite well when you
know how much they've been banged up and
dragged through the snow he does have
this coming but couldn't she wait this
public rejection is a pretty harsh fate
I don't question the sudden change in
her heart but do grinches and Hoos have
the same private parts one bulb to light
them all one bulb to find them one
question rules them all why does that
bulb light them so hairy
I've been looking closely for this beard
you've been dissing but what is this our
town
I swear that it's missing
still late you've wasted your
sentimental crap it was lost with that
butt kiss can't return from that uh-huh
it's funny because he's a dick
there comedy is about as subtle as a
brick green call the roast beef and how
would he figure that out exactly hasn't
he been eating glass throughout the
movie see now wasn't that easy to do no
and let's never do it again
agreed
[Music]
no one's canceling an email about your
bills the bank can pay off the back well
what about your cards and letters email
telephones fax machines FedEx telex
telegrams Holograms true of course
nobody needs mail how strange
bit of a slob isn't he all brilliant men
are
[Music]
today jr. do you wanna build a snowman
first for factory reject 21st floor
menswear
[Music]
you hear the truth you'll understand why
I put you back into it when you told me
about this candy crush game at first I
thought so much but now I can't stop
playing but you know that old Grinch was
so smart and so slick he thought up a
lie and he thought it up quick what's
this what's this what's this there's
white things in nature what's this I
can't believe my eyes I must be dreaming
wake up this isn't fair
[Music]
are
are you aiming for these people now
that mine